et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Marc fenault bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Julien Lecuyer de la
Voix du Nord bonjour Julien bonjour Yann
bonjour monsieur ministre bonjour on va
parler évidemment longuement des sujets
agricoles avec vous mais d'abord dans
l'actualité on a appris hier que le
petit neveu de Brigitte Macron avait été
gravement agressé violemment agressé
lundi soir par plusieurs individus dans
la foulée de l'interview du chef de
l'État en marge d'une manifestation
contre la réforme des retraites non
déclaré qu'elle a été votre réaction à
cette agression
hier soir puisque j'étais en débat au
Sénat
c'est une réaction quand même effrayante
de ce qui est le degré de violence
c'est-à-dire qu'au fond on est en train
tous ceux qui sont en train en
permanence de justifier de la violence
parce que la cause serait juste ou de
dire au fond tout ça c'est des
manifestations qui sont pacifiques on a
la démonstration que ça n'est pas le cas
et deux vous avez quelqu'un qui est
attaqué pour le seul motif de son lien
familial avec Brigitte Macron et avec
Emmanuel Macron vous je sais pas de quel
degré de terreur il va falloir
s'accommoder pour qu'un moment tout le
monde se mette autour de la table et
dénonce ces faits de violence
il y a toujours des il y a des oui mais
il y a des oui mais la violence sociale
oui mais la violence économique oui mais
on n'est pas d'accord avec il y a pas de
oui mais quand il y a de la violence il
y a il y a jamais aucune cause qui ne
justifie de la violence physique qui est
souvent nourri au démarrage par de la
violence verbale il y a ça n'est pas
anodin de mettre la tête d'un président
de la République sur un bio et de
simuler des scènes des décapitations ce
n'est pas anodin de brûler des effigies
à l'effigie de telle ou telle collègue
mini ça pas anodin d'aller menacer des
gens devant leurs habitations
pour leur engagement on parlera
peut-être de l'élu de syndrome des gens
pour leurs engagements ou pour les
causes qu'ils défendent ou pour les
projets qui sont appelés à défendre pour
défendre parfois l'intérêt général ils
sont menacés pour eux-mêmes et ils sont
menacés pour leur famille mais où est-ce
qu'on où est-ce qu'on arrête cette
logique avec moi vous m'avez toujours
entendu dénoncé la violence quel que
soit la violence quel que soit l'élu
quel que soit la personne qui est
concernée il faut qu'on cesse dans le
débat public implicitement alors tout ça
est pernicieux parce que implicitement
du mieux c'est pas grave vous voyez bien
que c'est un jeu on entend monsieur
laissez-moi finir ma phrase on entend
Monsieur Mélenchon à longueur de trucs
c'est amusant c'est une façon de se
défouler non ça n'est pas une façon de
se défouler et je le dis très
solennellement il faut que ça s'arrête
on peut avoir des désaccords en
politique on peut avoir des débats
j'avais jusque tard cette nuit des
débats au Sénat je respecte je ne menace
pas mes adversaires et je n'incite pas
ceux qui peuvent avoir parfois des
esprits un peu égarés à passer à l'acte
parce que les mots précèdent les faits
les gestes de violence et donc il faut
que ça cesse il faut que chacun se
remette un peu en or demain il faut que
les esprits de Mélenchon entretient la
violence dans la société je vais pas
moi-même faire ce que fait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais Jean-Luc Mélenchon comme
moi comme tous les autres il a il porte
une responsabilité c'est d'apaiser le
débat de faire qu'il y a du débat
démocratique dans les enceintes où ils
doivent allier avoir lieu et pas dans la
rue à taper des gens pour le seul motif
de ce qu'on est en train de commenter on
commente la faire de quelqu'un qui part
pour ses liens familiaux pour ces liens
de sang et menacés et violenté dans la
rue mais où est-ce qu'on est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui lui-même qui a lui-même
fait l'objet de violence et même de d'un
projet de d'assassinat pour participer
c'est pas les violences ordinaires là
c'est des gens qui sont c'est du
terrorisme
aussi mais je veux dire c'est pas du
tout la même nature là c'est non mais
participe d’un climat général de
violence faire le tri de violence des
adversaires justement pour prolonger
pour prolonger sur ce sujet en effet la
première ministre Elisabeth borne
rencontrera ce soir Yannick Morez de
Saint-Brevin les pins il a été agressé à
plusieurs reprises vous le savez et il a
il a fini par démissionner démontre le
manque de soutien de l'État est-ce que
justement l'État a été suffisamment à
ses côtés et de façon générale auprès
des élus qui sont sans cesse menacés
municipal j'ai été maire d'abord j'ai vu
monter quand même j'ai la première fois
que j'ai été élu conseiller municipal en
95 donc j'ai une forme d'ancienneté dans
le métier si je peux dire désormais
hélas j'ai vu monter cette violence et
là le fait que auparavant la
conflictualité se régler entre voisins
la conflictualité se régler avec le
maire qui faisait figure de médiateur et
la conflictualité désormais pour les
mêmes motifs c'est à dire que espèce
d'incitation à la querelle et de
l'incitation à la querelle par la
violence verbale puis physique et donc
les mères sont confrontés à ces
violences les mers sont aussi
challengées dans j'ai un projet je suis
pas avec vous et je vous menace et ça
m'est arrivé comme un autre à l'époque
quels sont les sujets c'est que souvent
les mers ont intériorisé n'ont pas dit
donc on a besoin de verbaliser les
choses comme d'autres formes de violence
d'ailleurs c'est que il faut que les
mères puissent se saisir de la question
parce que quand on émerve et que
quelqu'un vous insulte ou je vais aller
tuer vous dites c'est un des moments
d'égarement et vous n'osez pas aller
chez gendarmes vous dites on va faire
monter la pression ce n'est pas le cas
pour le maire de ce matin qui avait
largement j'y réponds à Saint-Brevin et
donc on a besoin ça et c'est d'ailleurs
un certain nombre de dispositions
successives je quinquennat précédent qui
ont été prises pour que les associations
puissent être participé j'entends ce que
dit le maire alors il va être il va être
vu par la première ministre il
rencontrera aussi ma collègue Dominique
fort il échangera sur ce qu'il y a pu
faire défaut pas faire défaut il y a le
sentiment l'important c'est qu'il ait eu
le sentiment que il n'était pas assez
accompagné c'est même plus la question
des faits donc on a besoin sans doute de
renforcer notre arsenal de penser que
toute la chaîne il y a pas que l'État
les collègues mer
chacun tient une part de la de la
comment dirais-je de la chaîne de
solidarité qui fait qu'on pas un élu ou
quelqu'un qui porte un projet d'ailleurs
en soi mais l'élu il est détenteur d'une
spécificité c'est qu'il est élu pour
prendre des décisions et représente
l'intérêt général dans son territoire il
essaye de le représenter et donc on a
besoin sans doute de solidifier les
liens mais vous voyez bien que c'est un
il y a beaucoup de mer qui sont dans ces
situations là et qui abandonnent leur
mandat alors là 4000 élus locaux ont
démissionné depuis 2020 oui mais c'est
un climat de violent vous écoutez les
parlementaires il y en a beaucoup qui
dit je ne retournerai plus jamais à
l'Assemblée nationale mais non mais on
me menace chez moi on a mûrait mon
domicile et ça c'est la démocratie qu'on
entrave donc il faut défendre ce maire
ou cet ancien maire est défend le
principe que l'intérêt général que les
gens qui s'engagent ils doivent être
encouragés pas découragés et pas menacés
vous avez 500 000 élus locaux il faut
qu'on prête attention il faut faire
attention au bruit au bruit là aussi il
y a une responsabilité d'un certain
nombre de gens qui a appelé à manifester
et qui a montré du doigt se maire c'est
monsieur Zemmour et ses amis c'est
Madame Le Pen et ses amis et qui
maintenant disent je recuse la violence
mais quand vous montrez du doigt comme
ça des gens et avec les mots qui ont été
employés évidemment vous incitez des
gens donc ils ont une part de
responsabilité selon vous mais tout le
monde a une part de responsabilité
l'État doit accompagner et s'il y a des
choses et ça sera regardé mais je ne
crois pas sur ce sujet là mais on verra
je vais pas grief au maire et puis il
faut pas entretenir de querelles en plus
mais ceux qui parlent de la violence
comme ça qu'il a justifie ou qu'il a
légitime ils ont une responsabilité on
va parler de la réforme des retraites
oui puisque les trois groupes de la
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale ont
décidé hier de s'opposer à la
proposition de loi visant à abroger la
réforme des retraites en brandissant un
argument qui est celui de cette
constitutionnalité en se basant sur
l'article 40 qui empêche de créer de
nouvelles dépenses publiques ou
d'affaiblir le le budget est-ce que
c'est la bonne stratégie selon vous
c'est pas une question de stratégie
c'est une question de fait ce texte
enfin moi je l'ai dit il y a quelques
jours sur une autre antenne enfin
l'article 40 ça existe il a pas été
inventé par les parlementaires il a été
produit par Michel Debré le général de
Gaulle en 58 l'articarol n'est pas un
article nouveau c'est un article qui a
été créé dès la constitution de 58 et
qui dit quoi qui dit que on ne peut pas
engager une dépense nouvelle c'est à
constitutionnel dès lors que l'État ne
lève pas le gage c'est un fait qu'on
pose la question du loi si ce texte
était déféré au Conseil constitutionnel
tout le monde a le droit de le déférer
il serait jugé inconstitutionnel sans
doute pourquoi parce qu'il n'aurait il
aurait enfin le principe de l'article 40
ce qui est le cas pour une grande partie
des textes de loi qui sont déposés à
l'Assemblée nationale les personnes qui
sont spécialistes de la vie
parlementaire le savent très bien il y a
beaucoup de propositions qui sont
assises sur une augmentation des détails
sur les alcools et les tabacs ça passe
quand même et pourtant là quand même
quelque chose de particulier dans ces
cas-là le gouvernement on dit qu'il lève
le gage
et là pardon c'est un petit qui c'est un
tout petit gage c'est un gage à 14
milliards
il faut que les gens qui portent ça et
qui remettent en cause au fond la
Constitution la Constitution il faut
qu'ils aient un amendement qui vise à
supprimer l'articante mais alors à tout
ou alors on ouvre une porte je le dis
parce que on vit dans un état de droit
c'est pas parce qu'on est dans un moment
éruptif et dans un moment où il y a des
gens qui ont perdu complètement le sens
des choses que il faut s'affranchir de
tout tes règles y compris les règles
constitués attendez je finis il a passé
le texte a passé la commission mais
peut-être que ce qui s'est passé moi je
vous demanderai au président de la
commission des finances pourquoi il a
jugé qu'il ce texte n'entraînait pas une
dépense supplémentaires et qui donc il
était recevable mais c'est lui que vous
avez dangereux c'est pas moi je viens
pas m'interférer dans ces affaires là
mais si vous ouvrez cette boîte là sans
rien dire ça veut dire que vous pouvez
faire tous les jours des textes à 20
milliards sans vous soucier le moins du
monde de son financement quand même le
sujet des retraites qu'est-ce qui a
justifié la réforme des retraites c'est
pas le plaisir d'être en défaut avec les
Français de nourrir des querelles avec
eux c'est que nous avons un système de
retraite qui est déficitaire déjà
aujourd'hui et qui valait demain la
seule question qui compte à l'endroit de
la proposition de la au-delà de la
question constitutionnelle c'est qui
paye qui finance
attendez là l'humilité de la majorité
est quand même est-ce que vous n'hésite
pas ce texte peut passer donc
est-ce qu'on a le droit dans une
démocratie de simplement rappeler ce qui
est la règle constitutionnelle sans
est-ce qu'on a le droit j'ai entendu
l'autre jour quelqu'un dire faut pas
qu'on fasse de l'obstruction on se fait
donner la leçon dans la majorité par des
gens qui ont fait 20 000 à 30000
amendements et quand on en ferait 100 on
ferait de l'obstruction mais on a dévoyé
on a bien entendu la musique ces
derniers temps
depuis quelques semaines puisque vous ne
savez pas par quel bout attaquer ce
texte qui en effet une épine dans le
pied du gouvernement on l'entend bien
puisque il risque de d'être voté s'il
passe dans la dans la dans l'hémicycle
mais cela dit est-ce que vous il y a pas
une sorte de je répète le mot de
stratégie et qui est en plus délétère
puisque certains comme Laurent Berger
patron de la CFDT qui dit que si le
texte ne passe pas ce serait
inacceptable Bertrand pencher le
président du groupe piote qui a déposé
la le texte dit ce serait un bâton de
dynamique qui serait allumé est-ce que
il a aussi une responsabilité quel bâton
de dynamique quelle
responsabilités on a commencé par la
violence c'est pas un bâton de dynamite
on peut avoir un désaccord politique on
peut avoir un désaccord démocratique
enfin c'est pas un bâton dynamique un
bâton dynamique c'est un truc concret
alors je vais au bout de la réponse
pardon de le dire on a un déficit sur le
le le les retraites à moins que Monsieur
pencher nous dise le contraire le texte
il vit simplement à supprimer le passage
de 62 64 et qu'est-ce qui propose pour
financer une conférence sociale oui
d'accord ça c'est pas l'irresponsabilité
ça non ça c'est pas grave de dire je ne
sais pas comment finance j'abroge ah si
si vous avez fait une erreur il propose
d'augmenter les taxes sur les tabacs et
boissons ça fera ça fera plaisir dans
l'opinion publique c'est quand même un
haut degré d'irresponsabilité et j'ai le
droit de le dire et c'est pas une
insulte que de dire que quand vous avez
un déficit comme celui-là il est pas
illégitime pardon pas faire offense à
personne mais que dans le débat
démocratique même la majorité fût-elle
relative fut-elle relative disent
comment finance
or là c'est je supprime je garde
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
dispositions de du projet de loi tel
qu'il a été validé par le Conseil
constitutionnel qui elle crée de la
dépense et je ne dis pas un mot de
comment je finance mais qui se moque de
qui là donc c'est un institutionnalité
vous la vous la soulèverez
on a beaucoup de sujets abordés et
d'abord l'inquiétude majeure des
agriculteurs c'est la sécheresse ou les
pluies dans certains cas comme le nord
c'est plutôt on va on va en parler
est-ce que concernant la sécheresse les
plus de ces dernières semaines ont
permis d'améliorer la situation des
agriculteurs on en est où aujourd'hui
les plus ont quand même amélioré que le
rendement la situation sur les trois
quarts du pays nous avions une
inquiétude qui était née d'une
pluviométrie très inférieure en février
elle a été très supérieure en mars
plutôt supérieur en avril et plutôt dans
la moyenne au moins on met le moine
n'étant pas terminé
avec des températures par ailleurs qui
sont des températures plutôt sous les
moyennes saisonnières ce qui m'invite à
deux choses la première c'est qu'il faut
qu'on nous politique qu'on s'évite de
commenter la météo tous les matins parce
que je pense qu'on a besoin de raisonner
à 30 ans ce sujet du dérèglement
climatique et pas est-ce qu'il va faire
beau dans 15 jours ça c'est l'affaire
des météorologues et moi qui suis assez
passionné de météorologie je le laisse
sur mes météorologues pas qu'on commande
parce que vous avez raison je l'avais
d'ailleurs dit au moment du salon
d'écriture j'ai dit attention on est en
train de parler de sécheresse et dans
deux mois vous verrez on dirait il y a
trop d'eau chez nous c'est le cas on est
voilà et c'est le cas chez vous donc
c'est mieux alors ça veut pas dire que
l'état des nappes c'est amélioré ça veut
dire juste que la pluviométrie est en
rendez-vous et parfois trop au
rendez-vous on a moins de besoin
d'irrigation je pense aux céréales à la
paille dans une région comme la mienne
manifestement comment plus les
températures ont été normal il y aura
pas besoin d'irrigation alors ça veut
pas attendez plus clair juste sur les
conséquences pour les récoltes
on est le 15 mais alors maintenant on
est dans un espèce d'anticipation on ne
connaît
d'inquiétude au delà de ce que peuvent
nourrir des inquiétudes d'influctuation
et puis dans le sud plutôt sur
effectivement les fruits
aussi le maraîchage mais le maraîchage
c'est plus réparti dans le sud c'est
quand même le l'arboriculture est très
présent trop tôt aussi pour dire si on
va devoir payer plus cher parce qu'on
voit bien j'étais dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales que il y a des
arbres qu'on est obligé qu'on est obligé
de délester de leur fruit parce qu'ils
ne pourront pas supporter la sécheresse
pour eux-mêmes et pour les fruits donc
faut supprimer il faut faire un choix de
récolte ou de non récoltes et donc là on
peut penser qu'il y aura une raréfaction
d'autant plus que d'ailleurs
pêche nectarines des sujets comme ça les
fruits de cette nature du coup plus cher
on peut pas dire mais il peut y avoir un
risque et ce d'autant qui vient se
rajouter un sujet c'est que de l'autre
côté de la frontière pyrénéenne les
Espagnols eux sont très gravement
touchés sur la quasi-totalité de leur
territoire par un épisode de sécheresse
intense donc on a besoin donc ça c'est
la vigilance du court terme après on a
besoin de construire territoire par
territoire une forme de résilience
cette année dans le dans les hauts de
France c'est trop d'eau je personne ne
sait dire aussi dans 5 ans dans les
Hauts-de-France c'est pas pas assez
d'eau oui voire même si dans trois mois
il y aura pas voilà en effet une
nouvelle canicule personne ne le sait
mais donc on a besoin de construire en
revanche une résilience des systèmes
agricoles la résilience c'est pas la
disparition c'est quels sont les modèles
qui seront les mieux adaptés
à des phénomènes climatiques qui
s'intensifient trop d'eau pas assez
d'autres d'autres choses souvent mais
juste une précision sur la question de
l'eau parce que quand Emmanuel Macron a
présenté son plan haut dans la foulée
vous étiez devant le Congrès de la nsea
et vous je leur avais dit que les
agriculteurs n'auraient pas à fournir
d'efforts supplémentaires et n'auront
donc pas à baissé leur prélèvement la
semaine dernière sur LCP Christophe
BECHU votre collègue mise de la
transition écologique assure que la
filière agricole sera concernée par les
efforts à fournir son métier c'est le
prélèvement net peut rester stable parce
qu'on va avoir besoin de plus
d'irrigation
en France parce qu'il y a des
territoires qui n'avaient pas besoin je
pense à la filière pomme de terre c'est
des territoires où on arrosé un peu les
pommes de terre mais il y a des zones
maintenant qui sont plus en nécessité
simplement les efforts que doit faire
l'agriculture c'est les efforts de
sobriété à l'hectare c'est ce que
j'avais d'ailleurs dit à l'endroit où
vous indiquez dans le congrès de la
finesse le prélèvement net dire qu'on va
le réduire surtout dans un pays comme le
nôtre qui a un 6% des surfaces seulement
sont irrigués en France 10 15 20% on est
moins en surface irriguée que les
Pays-Bas bon donc on n'est pas on peut
pas il faut pas se vider surtout
flageller simplement on a besoin de
sobriété à l'hectare parce que il y a il
y a un besoin de prise de conscience
collective mais les agriculteurs l'ont
déjà pris pour faire en sorte que chaque
goutte utilisé soit le mieux utilisé le
plus efficace mais vous confirmez qu'il
y aura pas de baisse d'après la fin mais
l'idée c'est d'avoir une stabilisation
sur la partie agricole pourquoi parce
qu'on a besoin
non baisse des prélèvements c'est déjà
un effort parce que beaucoup nous
demandaient une augmentation des
prélèvements agricoles mais une non
baisse ça passe par une sobriété à
l'état mais en demandait plus que ça
c'est renoncer à l'agriculture
l'autre sujet d'inquiétude c'est la
résurgence de la grippe aviaire il y a
combien de cas aujourd'hui sur le
territoire il est un peu plus de 300 on
a surtout une inquiétude sur une
résurgence dans le Sud-Ouest c'est une
zone qui avait été assez épargnée à
bâtir une trentaine de cas en une
dizaine de jours
malheureusement sans conscience alors ça
c'est la science qui documentera sans
qu'on sache pourquoi c'est très urgent
on sait que vous savez très bien comme
moi que théoriquement la grippe aviaire
c'était plutôt autonale en fonction des
migrations l'an dernier on a vu
apparaître le fait que
on avait plutôt une présence permanente
du virus et qui n'était pas liée aux
migration des oiseaux
et mes théoriquement quand on arrive au
printemps les températures font que la
grippe aviaire disparaît qu'on a une
période de pause plutôt entremet et
septembre octobre malheureusement là on
a une résurgence un peu inexpliquée
d'ailleurs enfin bon hier je réunissais
les acteurs de la filière et la
stratégie mais c'est la stratégie qui va
être celle habituelle c'est les
confinement c'est le des peuplements
vous avez 31 foyers vous avez une zone
autour du foyer vous avez le foyer et
vous avez une zone un peu plus large
pour éviter les contaminations on sait
que c'est une contamination qui est
large donc mesure classique
malheureusement donc ça c'est un point
de d'inquiétude et puis deux sur une ici
aussi les acteurs de la filière parce
qu'on a heureusement aujourd'hui une
solution vaccinale en particulier pour
les canards qui sont ceux qui sont les
plus vecteurs du virus et on travaille
actuellement à au déploiement comme je
m'étais engagé devant les éleveurs
d'ailleurs au déploiement d'un vaccin
pour le mois de septembre octobre pour
que la saison prochaine alors ça
éliminera pas le virus mais ça
normalement ce vaccin ce vaccin qui a
été expérimenté à grande vitesse aussi
c'est en moins d'un an il permet
d'éviter la surcontamination donc ça
sera septembre ça concernera là aussi
parce que là il y avait des têtes
expérimentations là ça sera généralisé
dernier résultat de l'expérimentation
l'idée c'est d'expérimenter sur enfin de
généraliser sur l'ensemble de terr
ça serait mieux sur ces sujets là parce
que l'agriculture souffre et les
agriculteurs encore plus sont beaucoup
plus trop des caricatures qui leur sont
pas une régression il y a dans ce texte
des sujets qui sont à mon avis juste
c'est la question de la compétitivité
j'ai l'impression que le mot
compétitivité gêné pour certains dans
l'hémicycle enfin nous sommes dans une
filière économique c'est pas une filière
esthétique l'agriculture il y a besoin
que les gens gagnent leur vie il y a
besoin que dans la concurrence je parle
pas de la concurrence mondiale la
concurrence européenne on est une
agriculture qui soit compétitive donc le
mot compétitivité n'est pas un mauvais
registre et c'est en cela que
l'initiative du sénateur du plan du
sénateur lourd du sénateurs Mario de la
rapporteur présidente Sophie proma est
une bonne initiative parce qu'il y a des
dispositions sur lesquelles ils ont
voulu pointer du doigt la question du
portage de capitaux de l'épargne la
question de comment on a une
réglementation qui ne vient pas se sur
Ajouter à celle qui existe déjà comment
on essaie de raccourcir les délais puis
il y avait des objets de désaccord avec
le Sénat là aussi on peut le dire oui
sans tomber dans la caricature qui est
en particulier la remise en cause d'un
certain nombre d'équilibre qui ont été
et qui sont le fruit non pas de la
majorité qui soutenait François Hollande
mais aussi sous Nicolas Sarkozy parce
que le principe de précaution c'est sous
Jacques Chirac le Grenelle de
l'environnement et la trajectoire de
baisse des pesticides c'est sous Nicolas
Sarkozy avec Jean-Louis Borlo donc
chacun a fait son œuvre simplement on a
besoin de penser en conscience quels
sont les outils de la modernisation et
je trouve que ce texte de loi et j'ai
dit hier ce en quoi le gouvernement
était en accord et ce en quoi le
gouvernement était en désaccord sur un
débat démocratique ce sur quoi vous êtes
en désaccord c'est notamment une
disposition qui qui doit permettre au
ministre de l'Agriculture que vous êtes
de suspendre une décision de l'ancêtre
qui interdirait certains produits
phytosanitaires pourquoi vous n'y êtes
pas favorable parce que je trouve que
l'équilibre qui a été trouvé je pense
que c'est était maintenant posé sur la
table et que revenir en permanence sur
les dispositions en fait on a un
problème en France on change la loi
est-ce qu'on peut pas simplement ce que
j'ai dit d'ailleurs y compris dans la la
polémique qui est née de ce que j'avais
dit sur l'onces dans ces selles elles
aimaient elle a mis des avis et il est
pas illégitime que étant n'étant pas une
aut indépendante c'est une agence de
l'État sous cotutelle de 5 ministères
c'est pas une insulte c'est pas
révolutionnaire c'est pas remettre en
cause la science que de dire on a besoin
de débat d'ailleurs sur la grippe
aviaire je le rappelais aux écologistes
ils ont été les premières à remettre en
cause les préconisations de l'ancêtre
sur les nitrites ils sont les premiers à
dire je ne suis pas d'accord avec donc
on peut avoir ce débat là mais il me
semble que remettre en cause et d'une
certaine façon subrepticement d'ailleurs
la présidente prima a dit la question
n'est pas de remettre en cause
l'excellence du travail et la science
donc à ce moment-là nous remettons pas
en cause cela et essayons avec l'anxess
de construire une stratégie qui soit pas
seulement la stratégie de l'analyse
scientifique et qui est juste et qui est
nécessaire mais la stratégie de la
transition et des alternatives à trouver
parce que l'ancêtre est-ce que la
mission de lancer c'est pas d'avoir un
avis scientifique sur des produits type
le S mais metola chlore et pas de
s'interroger sur le fait de savoir si on
a des équation et c'est le bon timing
par rapport à la réglementation
européenne pardon de dire que si je
trouve pas que les questions qui est
posées dans ce registre et pas
complètement idiote parce que
attendez le smeto la clore est un
herbicide
un désherbant donc chimique s'il est
interdit en France et pas dans les 26
pays européens qu'est-ce que j'ai gagné
je sais pas la santé des gens non mais
c'est une question
à dire que les 26 autres pays se moquent
totalement de la santé des gens quel
jugement d'arrogance quand même nous
aurions à dire ça
non mais vous avez raison mais est-ce
qu'on peut poser la question sans faire
insultes de dire les 26 autres les
Allemands le collègue allemand il est il
vient de chez les Verts bon il est pas
suspect donc par nature et c'est
quelqu'un qui je travaille très bien par
ailleurs mais chez eux ils ont ils l'ont
pas fait pour l'instant si c'est au
niveau européen c'est un double avantage
1 on crée pas de distorsion entre nous
et de ça permet de l'imposer aux
frontières
réglementation ça peut s'assumer
d'ailleurs hier ce qui était amusant
c'est qu'il comprit les sénateurs
proposer la surexlementation mais si on
peut le faire dans une chronologie qui
soit crédible mais ça serait mieux ce
qui veut pas dire qu'on veut en rabattre
sur la question de la réduction des
phytos marché
file on va dire un mot des sénatorial
puisque ça aurait lieu en septembre vous
êtes chargé des négociations au sein de
la majorité pour le modem on ça vous
occupe un petit peu j'ai l'impression
est-ce qu'il y aura des listes communes
modem Renaissance horizon pour les
scénaristes vous savez aussi mieux que
moi-même parce que le Sénat c'est quand
même une assemblée particulière vous
savez très bien que c'est à la fois dans
les scrutins parfois plusieurs listes
qui s'expriment pour des raisons
diverses et variées bonnes ou moins
bonne d'ailleurs pour parfois contourner
la parité on va pas dire le contraire
et ça c'est valable dans tous les partis
vous avez parfois des querelles à
l'intérieur qui créent c'est valable
dans tous les partis je vois ça partout
et donc ça peut arriver et y compris
dans la majorité vous avez des scrutins
illuminaux c'est pas tellement
l'étiquette qui compte mais c'est la
personnalité il y a des gens qui sont
élus sur leur territoire normalement ça
ne correspond pas à l'étiquette du
territoire donc il y aura des listes
communes il y aura des listes qu'on
soutiendra en commun il y a des gens qui
ne demandent pas de soutien mais qui
bénéficieront au fond de la
bienveillance et de la
la non compétition avec avec
nos listes ou avec des candidats de chez
nous enfin il y a toutes ces formules là
donc
dans ces cas là vous savez quand vous
regardez la candidature et l'étiquetage
c'est plutôt des divers c'est le règne
vous êtes optimiste sur un accord oui
mais attention
c'est réinvesti d'emblée tous ces
sortants sans vous prévenir ça a créé un
point de vue je pense qu'on a besoin de
se parler qu'on a besoin d'avoir des des
je pense qu'une négociation d'abord il
doit être secrète et j'ai toujours mené
les négociations nous racontant pas ce
qui s'y passe que je pense que l'arrière
cuisine n'a pas d'intérêt je peux aller
elle est pas affreuse mais c'est juste
ça n'a pas d'interrompre en cours de
chemin c'est important c'est le résultat
et donc moi je veille à faire en sorte
que tout le monde s'en représenté qu'on
préserve les sortances qui n'empêche pas
le débat de dire est-ce que celui-là est
mieux positionné qu'un autre et ça
n'empêche pas chez nous comme ailleurs
qui puisse avoir des désaccords mais je
ne savais une idée de la répartition
entre Renaissance horizon mais que je
vous donnerai pas là parce que nous
sommes justement pour les raisons que je
viens d'évoquer en cours de discussion
et que je n'ai pas envie de présenter un
débat parce que c'est un travail qui
doit se faire à trois et personne ne
peut sortir du bois sans les autres et
Monsieur le Ministre dernière question
mais à force de vous occuper des est-ce
que ça vous donne pas envie d'y
participer j'aime beaucoup le Sénat vous
le savez je l'aime depuis 22 ans
je crois pas que ce soit le bon timing
pour être très honnête et essayer de
répondre franchement à votre question
mais j'aime beaucoup
la répétition d'être un homme pressé
puis si c'est pas dans 6 ans avec c'est
pas possible mais ce sera pas là ce sera
j'ai été élu sur mon territoire comme
parlementaire je suis devenu ministre de
l'Agriculture je trouve qu'il y a aussi
quelque chose de l'ordre du respect des
électeurs que auquel j'essaie de me
tenir et de pour éviter de donner des
leçons aux autres il faut s'appliquer à
soi-même des principes et donc j'essaie
de me tenir assez du pas que je suis
pareil que de toutes les vertus mais je
ne crois pas que ce soit le moment même
si vraiment je reconnais me sentir
particulièrement bien au Sénat depuis
très longtemps merci
du Nord on en parlait chant gorgée d'eau
enfin une éclaircie oui mais avec toutes
les difficultés que ça peut provoquer en
effet et c'est à dire merci Julien merci
Marc fenouil